imagine if you spent two years of your
life
immersed in the study of the greatest
ideas that have ever been spoken
written or created imagine if you
actually wrestled with these ideas
and allowed yourself to be shaped by
them would those years
change your understanding of yourself of
the world and of others
would they challenge your assumptions
and beliefs would they affect
the way you think the choices you make
even the trajectory of your life
we know that's pretty lofty stuff but
it's exactly what hillsdale's
core curriculum is designed to do the
core curriculum is the foundation of a
liberal arts education at hillsdale
throughout your first two years at
hillsdale you'll read classical
literature
and contemplate human nature you'll
debate timeless
philosophical and theological traditions
and wrestle with the deepest questions
in life
you'll learn the history heritage and
design of our nation
and examine the foundational ideals of
freedom and self-government
and you'll explore the rules wonders and
design of our physical world
these aren't disconnected gen eds meant
to make you well-rounded
but a deep and systematic study of the
most important things
we believe that these interconnected
disciplines that make up hillsdale's
core curriculum
are worth studying for their own sake
because they are time
tested and universally relevant because
they are good
true and beautiful and because together
they create for us a window to
our past and the gateway to our future